sometime in the next few years the
classic iron man storyline armor wars
will be adapted into its own disney plus
miniseries
but just what happens during this arc
and how does it fit into the wider
marvel universe
this is iron man's armor wars explained
one of the most famous iron man stories
is a demon in a bottle arc
in which tony stark's dependence on
alcohol turns into a full-blown
addiction
although he recovers once or twice he
later relapses
ends up losing his company and is left
drunkenly wandering the streets of new
york
hoping to set up a new business in
california stark acquires a small
company called
acutec which has been working on all
kinds of cutting-edge energy technology
and recently turned down an ownership
bid from the villainous roxanne
corporation
they were right to do so too as roxanne
reacts by hiring a legendary industrial
saboteur
named the ghost to bring the company to
its knees the ghost is out to get stark
on a personal level however
and even when roxanne tells him to back
off he carries on with his vendetta
roxanne subsequently sends a long-time
ironman foe spymaster to kill the ghost
but the ghost quickly turns the tables
killing spymaster by materializing him
in the middle of a wall the ghost later
dies by his own hand
whilst trying to bring down iron man
himself meanwhile a longtime operative
of justin hammer named force goes rogue
having become tired of causing trouble
for his nefarious boss
force turns to stark who helps him fake
his death and gives him a job in
exchange for a little
information and forces armor of course
the first chapter of armor wars begins
with stark examining force's armor
here he makes a horrifying discovery
that there's circuitry in the suits that
he himself
created and was supposed to be so secret
that he'd never even patented it
stark has no idea who stole it however
or when or how
but he's determined to find out mostly
out of guilt for the pain caused by the
villains who have previously had
access to his tech the very technology
that you designed to keep yourself alive
is being used to commit atrocities
endless opportunities for terrorist
misery
because of what i built stark initially
deduces that it was justin hammer who
stole his tech
he turns to his colleague abe zimmer to
help him hack into hammer's database
but zimmer needs an inside man to help
so start goes to his old electronics
whiz friend and employee scott lang
who just moved to california unbeknownst
to stark lang is also
ant-man and so he helps zimmer get what
he needs a computer file containing a
list of everyone
who has benefited from stark's stolen
technology
next stock builds a scanner to track
down his tech when it's in use
as well as a special negator pack to
help destroy it
the first name on the list is a
lesser-known villain stiltman who is
grievously injured in an ensuing fight
with iron man
stark then tracks down the mauler who
gives up his armor willingly and the
controller who puts up more of a fight
leading to the death of one of the
villain's followers
following the battles at the end of amma
war's first issue tony stark is taken to
court
first by stiltman who claims iron man
used excessive force in apprehending him
and then by the controller's cult who
take him up on a violation of freedom of
religion
meanwhile iron man continues his
vendetta by frying the armor of the trio
of mercenaries called the raiders
that just so happened to be working for
his old corporate enemy edwin cord
who has fouled revenge for stark putting
him out of business years earlier
abe zimmer calls stark and tells him
that due to a glitch in the file there
is one name that isn't properly showing
up
stark analyzes a list of armored heroes
and villains and realizes that the only
one he couldn't account for was a
part-time avenger and oceanographer
stingray
iron man then flies the hydro base and
demands to examine stingray's armor
who outright refuses to cooperate iron
man then chases down stingray
tricks him into a trap and stuns him
when he slaps at a gator back onto his
armor however
nothing happens turns out stark's hunch
was wrong
knowing there will be consequences for
his actions and with multiple threats of
governmental lawsuits looming
stark holds a press conference and fires
his longtime employee
and bodyguard iron man considering the
world doesn't know that stark
is iron man at this point of course this
turns out to be a pretty clever play on
his part
after hunting down the villain known as
the beatle and hitting him with a
negator back
stark is contacted by hawkeye who speaks
on behalf of the west coast avengers
when hawkeye demands to know what's
really going on with iron man
stark insists that he can't tell him why
he's on this particular vendetta
and simply ask for their trust instead
later stack arrives at his office to
find nick fury and several shield agents
are waiting for him having invented a
false secret identity for iron man named
randall pierce
sark offers to help fury track down
beerus in exchange for getting iron
man's armor back
as it turns out however stark set up
this elaborate ruse to make fury think
he was on his side
also that he could get access to the
shield mandroids sophisticated suits of
armor that were built with stark tech
i'm sure iron man won't destroy them all
and make my conscience just a little bit
clearer
obviously stark doesn't enjoy the idea
of deceiving his allies in the
government
but by this point he's convinced that
they too must be stopped
stark tricks fury into sending the
mandroids to capture iron man
and then sets them the gator pack traps
that successfully knock out two of them
he makes short work of two more as well
but soon runs into a problem
the last one is standing alongside a
number of unarmored field agents
not wanting to be caught up in the
crossfire iron man uses sonic weapons to
knock out the agents
and then captures the final mandroid
after the pilot eject some fleece
when fury later accuses stark of
betraying him tony produces a bug that
iron man had supposedly planted on him
thereby sidestepping any guilt for his
role in shield's defeat
at this point in time steve rogers has
been forced to give up his captain
america identity by the government
in response he simply starts calling
himself the captain
and turns to tony stark for a new shield
stark is more than happy to help of
course
hoping that if steve owes him a favor he
might just stay out of his way in return
sadly that plan doesn't quite work out
and the captain quickly gets his stark's
next target
the guardsmen an elite squad who guards
a supervillain prison known as
the vault the captain catches stark
before he can bluff his way in however
so stark beats the hasty retreat luckily
stark has a new plan
he has jim rhodes pretend to be electro
in order to get sent to the vault
once inside rhodes shuts down the
defenses and floods the place with
knockout gas
brodie and iron man then disable 40
suits of guardsman armor
luckily most of them were off-duty
leaving just half a dozen still able to
put up a fight
iron man is about to deal with the last
one before the captain who has
anticipated iron man's break-in
finally steps in while the captain helps
to down guardsmen
iron man takes the opportunity to
immobilize him with electricity
while iron man succeeds in his mission
this confrontation with rogers marks the
beginning of a rift
that would only widen over the coming
years finally culminating in the
devastating civil war storyline
almost 20 years later unfortunately iron
man's actions at the vault
inadvertently lead to the breakout of
several high-profile prisoners
subsequently hawkeye tells iron man that
his vendetta must come to an end
but stark well pretty much just ignores
him by this point he has just two names
left on his list
both of whom reside in the soviet union
the crimson dynamo and the titanium man
the dynamo is still very much loyal to
the state but the titanium man is
piloted by a villain called the gremlin
who has no love for the soviets iron man
tracks down the titanium man in his
special stealth armor
taking him completely by surprise having
been warned about iron man's rampage the
dynamo
shows up hoping to pick off the survivor
of the battle
but iron man quickly uses a negator pack
to neutralize him when he tries to do
the same
thing to the titanium man however the
latter crushes the pack
in the ensuing fight iron man ends up
accidentally overheating the titanium
man's armor and killing the gremlin
inside things only get worse when iron
man returns home
as he is thrown out of the avengers and
declared a traitor by the united states
government
meanwhile edwin cord uses stalden stark
technology
to develop a new suit of highly
weaponized armor that he calls firepower
pilots hid by a psychopathic villain
named jack taggart
cord subsequently hires out firepower
services to senator boynton who hopes to
use the suit as a deterrent for any
superheroes who spiral out of control
to set an example cord and boynton
decide to use firepower to kill iron man
while this is taking place abe zimmer
concocts a way to solve stark's tech
problem
he develops a tapeworm virus that will
destroy every last trace of his armor
technology
and then replicate itself into
perpetuity soon after boynton shows up
in stark's office and demands that he
help lure iron man into a trap
where firepower will destroy him stark
decides to take the bait
knowing that firepower was the glitch he
had missed earlier during that battle
firepower's heavy weapon systems and
armored coating
quickly overwhelm iron man so he tries
to outmaneuver him in a gulch
bringing a rock slide down on the
villain firepower shrugs it off but iron
man then uses firepower's molten rock
against him
disorienting taggett for long enough to
apply a negator pack to his armor
but nothing happens firepower reveals
that the government has analyzed the
equipment and found a way to shield
against iron man's attempted sabotage
iron man is then forced to make his
escape in a helicopter piloted by jim
rhodes
but when it becomes clear that roadie's
life is at risk iron man leaps back out
again
and is immediately destroyed by one of
firepower's nuclear missiles
of course it soon turns out that stark
faked the death of iron man
putting a little blood inside his armor
and remotely piloting it to its doom
bruised and beaten stark is more than
happy to let iron man stay dead and
move on with his life when boynton comes
to claim the firepower armor that he
financed however
cord refuses to give it up as he now has
his own agenda
destroying tony stark first he uses
firepower to intimidate the people doing
business with him
then firepower begins destroying company
property finally he delivers a message
to the man himself
quit stark enterprises or die stark
responds by building a brand new iron
man suit
specifically designed to defeat
firepower which he vows to destroy
as soon as the threat is dealt with
predictably firepower shows up at a new
branch opening for stark enterprises
and in the battle that follows it
becomes clear that iron man has a
counter for every one of firepower's
tricks when firepower finally attempts
to launch one of his nuclear missiles
he discovers to his horror that it has
jammed iron man uses an electromagnetic
pulse to shut down firepower's systems
and then uses his computer to find the
cancellation code for the nuke
defeated and humiliated firepower points
out that more like him will come
which finally convinces stark to keep
iron man alive
the armor wars arc ends with stark going
home victorious
and finally getting some well-deserved
rest all right hey
all right good job guys let's just not
come in tomorrow
let's just take a date you ever tried
shawarma
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite comics are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
you